your wife michelle told me that you are
afraid of sasha is that true
yes yes and the reason is because
sasha is a mini michelle sure
barack obama may have been leader of the
free world for two terms in the white
house
but the man knows who's really boss just
something i do
the 44th president of the united states
appeared on jimmy kimmel live
thursday to promote his new memoir a
promised land
and revealed that his 19 year old
daughter sasha is
a whole lot like his wifey michelle i'm
afraid of michelle
and sasha having seen that
you know basically has the same look and
the same attitude
as for the couple's 22 year old daughter
malia she's more like
barack malia is more like me
temperamentally
so uh and we call ourselves the long
faces
uh because her face is more shaped like
mine and it's
the brown faces are michelle and sasha
and
and the round faces are a fiercer tribe
you know
we're like we're like the vegetarians
the
you know the the gatherers and they're
the hunters we we
try to you know keep the peace with them
since its tuesday release
a promised land has already become a
best-seller
even surpassing the former first ladies
2018 book
becoming rubbing it in over dinner
you know i i know although in truth
michelle's attitude is uh boy you go out
and
sell some books that's fine because that
will
pay for some of my shoes and while the
book is flying off the shelves
his daughters can't be bothered you are
never a prophet in your own land
they their attitude is
we've got better things to do to read
you're boring
you know rants and raves uh
they promise at some point they will uh
which in truth i think it took them like
10 years before they finally
picked up uh my first book so
i i suspect by the time they're 30 they
will have read it
so presidents they're just like
us when he walks into the residence he's
not the president of the united states
he's
he's dead in his memoir barack writes
about balancing politics with family
and he talked about all that with jimmy
too my dad wasn't there
when i was growing up and and when i uh
married michelle and we talked about
starting a family i said to myself
you know i'm going to do things
differently i'm i'm going to make sure
my daughters
know me they know they're loved they
know they're supported
and overall
i they'd say i think that uh i did a
good job on that front
and he says that being a dad actually
motivated him at the office
i i actually think i was a better
president because of that constant
reminder of you know what's the point
all this other than
making sure you're leaving a better
world for your kids
during a recent interview with 60
minutes barack admitted that michelle
didn't want him to run for president the
fact that i ended up winning
didn't necessarily alleviate
her her frustration because the toll it
takes on families
is real the fact that she
put up with it and forgave me
was uh an
act of of grace that i
uh am grateful for uh and i'm not sure i
deserved it
and in a separate interview with cbs
sunday morning he joked that we
shouldn't expect to see him join
president-elect joe biden's team in the
white house
for the sake of his marriage there are
probably some things i would not be
doing because michelle would leave me
yes she'd be like what